[Music]
why why did you click on this video okay
alright hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcomed penis cloner the
game now I'm gonna start a new one and
obviously a game like this needs some
background story on it you are a penis
you go on an adventure level 1 of 10 go
to the blue circle to win yep yep this
is what you all came for level 2 of 10
clone yourself with the machine
because the world needs more penis
[Music]
hey we won
awesome I'm questioning my life
decisions at this point don't clone too
many clone just enough press R to
restart when you poop up because you
will poop up o marks playing a game
about penises but won't say the word
poop I'm playing a game it's not even
it's not even penis it's just like four
pixels oh my god what am i doing what am
i doing what am i doing with my life
form patterns with penises okay this is
where this is where I'm in a new
territory years to life why not that
that is a good question I want to know
that how why what do I do
it's too many oh okay
a lonely penis is a sad penis let's just
go commit to this we're already in it
a sad penis is a small oh the same that
okay circle of life yo do you know don't
know the man for penis still high this
just did our news reports day from
wilfred horse fest this just said demand
for penis still i no end in sight as men
we can't really understand that
okay all right let's go for it man
let's go for it man all right man go for
it
I'm in no we have a problem here
oh no we're gonna have too many Pinay Oh
No what have we did whatever we oh no
that's wrong
oh and the world is consumed by penises
all right
well glad things just decided to get
complicated I would have been very very
bothered if it was not let's try that
now
ah crap oh crap oh crap oh wait I know
no I do not know but I think I know
again I gotta do this again I got it
though okay
wait no no there we go all right now
that that is there I can fit out with
enough of these all ah yeah I beat the
penis puzzle I'm so happy with myself
even though I shouldn't be adventure of
a penis never ends life of a penis is
full of surprises okay
penises know how to change their lives
[Laughter]
do they really is that what they really
do what have I done
what have I done honestly what have I
done my my channel is now permanently
scarred dive effed up oh yeah stop all
over the place maybe hang on maybe baby
Oh God Oh God wait no Oh God
Oh God yo so close I can't
Wow level 9 of 10 running out of penis
jokes oh really
you only had 10 you needed to come up
with though ha ha
I've almost been in the penis closer
game good ring it's so good for me why
am i doing yeah this isn't right I don't
know how to beat this don't wanna know
[Laughter]
they're just two blocks and a bigger
block that could be anything that could
be like a hammer or a portobello
mushroom with two stems caps whatever
trying to am I really trying to justify
be playing this penis game the answer is
yes I am very much so
oh god they don't know what to do here
I'm actually I'm actually in law school
you can't solve this penis puzzle what
do I do
um I uh viously need to make two batches
of them what how do I separate the
batches how do I separate the [ __ ]
don't know that damn it
tablet can't separate the [ __ ] how do
I do it
oh I don't know how to beat this penis
game maybe one of you who are really
interested in playing games like this
and are so happy to support the indie
game development community would like to
give this a try just just just just
forgive me don't unsubscribe where are
you going know if you're still here then
I mean you're basically committed to
seeing the rest of this game so I can
only assume that you're trying to shout
instructions and how I'm supposed to
solve this penis oh I know oh I know I
know how to do this oh it seems so
obvious now wait no that's not right
that's not right no there ah dang it I
had it okay I know how to beat this I
got this one and we scoot em over we
know oh god no oh God oh I did it again
I goofed I done goofed all over my
penises ignore I just said that okay so
this it was like this was like that Oh
close don't know how to I almost got it
it's right there the dancers in front of
my eyeballs ah yes maybe
yes ah iPad I got it this time I ask
shut up everybody I'm not used to this
just let me oh no oh no it's right there
right there I know it is gosh so close
how do I beat the penis game oh now I
really want to beat it now I really want
to beat and I bet anyone who's still
watching by now is like come on you can
do it you can beat this penis game and
I'm like I do it I do it for the
children and that's not right how do I
beat it
I really am almost there
I can feel it in the beat of my black
comeback
oh it's right there it's right there
right I'm almost got it but not quite I
need to fight the good I thought I had
it like two seconds ago I thought I was
like a step away from it but I was wrong
or else I haven't gotten back to exactly
what I did before which was like
something to do with this
and then
[Music]
oh no damn it guy thought I heared that
we may wear no does that'll do that and
that's a problem that it's so closes
right there they should probably stop
playing this but I'm really interested
in beating this oh it's right in front
of my eyes how am I not seeing this the
solution in our damage done goofed I
done goofed all over the place maybe I
still got it maybe I still got the magic
touch
oh no way to cloned another item oh it's
right in front of me it's right in front
of me I know it is it's just I can't go
left there is no one move unless I go
down unless down is the one move move
would be down I shouldn't be this happy
and you all should be happy for me I
know you all are cheering out there you
know you're all like yeah he did it or
you're like God added time to fill up
the world with your penis don't worry
guys it's not the time to fill up the
world with my piece in the game yes
absolutely sure why not
but right now no I know why I really I
don't I'm not gonna that that's not
what's gonna happen right now make that
very clear I'm not gonna fill the world
with Mike
[Music]
[Laughter]
why did nothing ah God oh what a
wonderful world what a wonderful world
this is all right how do I beat this get
back yes there we go oh no I'm so close
oh wait no I got this
penises well everywhere are you proud
surprisingly I am I'm very proud
wherever we look we see your penis
clones they are self-aware now they can
clone themselves without my permission
we're effed you asked up the whole world
are you happy
surprisingly yes congratulations you
beat the game penis but you're a dick my
self and originally I was not but now I
am I feel I feel a sense of joy that I
was able to beat that puzzle the only
the one puzzle really threw me and it
should have been more obvious come down
to the top it was the only way I should
have realized that at first but I did it
I'll bait the penis game if you want to
play the penis game it's oh god no the
link is not down there you're gonna have
to bind it on your own and don't Google
penis cloner I'm not responsible for
whatever strange websites you land on I
am NOT gonna be that person so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]